foreign
let's go to Aaron in Eugene Oregon
what's up Aaron
how's it going good brother what's up
it's good to talk to you yeah
I'll go with my question I uh constantly
right now kind of feel like I'm in
crisis mode
um I'm getting pretty burnt out and uh
I feel like I'm having trouble leading
my family uh let it come on
leading myself like spiritually and
mentally
why are you in crisis mode man
well
um
so my wife and I have been married for
three years we have two daughters ages
two and one
um we own a business so we started about
two years ago so we're pretty busy right
now
um I generally work about 14 hours a day
six days a week
um
in July we found out that my wife was
pregnant
and months later we found out that she
was pregnant with two babies we were
having twins wow
um and then uh fast forward to October
my wife went in for like a regular
ultrasound
um I wasn't able to be there I had to
work and they told her that the twins
were
in high high risk very very dangerous
situation that we needed to operate
um
and so we we've been in for surgery that
that day
um
and they the twins survived about three
four days after the surgery
we lost him
um
so yeah kind of in the aftermath of that
yeah
um and just
yeah no I just don't have time to deal
with that right now because we're we're
so busy our businesses are peak season
yeah
so it's just been
foreign
non-stop kind of thing yeah man dude I'm
sorry
I'm so sorry man
um
I can't I can't think of a
more radical trauma than losing two
twins with a two and a one-year-old on
top of that on top of a very young
marriage on top of a young business
trying to make it y'all got a lot man
so you say you're overwhelmed you should
be okay you're not crazy
and you're burning out and you are
melting down you should be
okay
and I'll walk with you on what some
things you can do but man
how's your wife doing
um
she's doing she's doing well
um like physically she's recovering
very well
um but you know it's
I'm not around to help as much as I
would like with the kids so what's your
business man it's hard on her
uh we have a mobile tire shop so we go
out to people's homes and and deliver
and install their tires okay excellent
um do you have people that work with you
or for you
uh we have one employee currently
okay
um are you just scratching are you just
scratching a clawing to make a living
are y'all doing pretty well
um like I would hire you to come to my
house right now and change my tires like
that sounds like an incredible business
yeah we're we're doing
I wouldn't say we're just scratching and
crying but it it's
owning your own business you know
everything kind of gets reinvested for
the first few years so it's not like
we're You Know Rich by any means yeah
yeah I mean yeah personally our finances
are really tight because we reinvest
everything into the business okay that
makes sense
I can't think of a better investment
right now
than to get some help and get you some
space
if you don't deal with the chaos in your
home and in your life and in your soul
right now it will deal with you
and it will take no mercy on you
and so when you're talking about an
investment in the business
sometimes the like
uh
if you are Usain Bolt and you are
training for yet another Olympics
a huge part of your training is rest
you're not just running Sprints every
single minute of every single day you
run really hard for a short burst and
then you rest
and right now your world just exploded
it already was chaotic with a two and a
one-year-old and a three-year-old
marriage
y'all barely said hello as a as a
married couple before you started
cranking out kids and then you had a big
time traumatic loss because you that's
long enough you made plans right
yeah you start thinking about life with
twins and two knucklehead little boys
running around
what were their names
Lawrence and Andrew yeah
they had names man they had to put the
place in your house
they had a place in your heart
you can't outrun that
you're gonna have to sit and own that
loss
and own that grief
and there's not a road map for that per
se but that's something that you and
your wife are gonna have to do
I just know too many couples that don't
grieve or they grieve differently
everybody agrees differently but they
grieve so differently that it splits
their marriage up it splits their
relationship up the younger kids feel
like they're crazy
because Mom's crying and they're
wondering what they did my mom's upset
dad's never like see what I'm saying
and I'm all about man I just I'm coming
off a season about to enter into another
season
um
of intense 14 16 hour days day after day
after day after day I get it there's
Seasons when you do that but you can't
run that way forever particularly on the
back of a trauma
is that fair
yeah your business may not be need to
grow grow for the next six months it may
need to just stay neutral just keep just
keep going keep doing great work and
hire two guys to come help so that you
can go home
and sit with your wife there will be
Seasons when you go back to the 14-hour
days and go back to the grind you go
back and doing those things it's going
to be important and it's going to be
good stuff it's gonna be right
um
right now you're the UFC fighter who got
knocked out
and whose body is so programmed to keep
going that he hops back up and just
starts swinging again ends up swinging
at the raft or tries to tackle the ref
you gotta and then it takes his coaches
and the doctor to sit him down and so
you got to stop
that's where you are man
now when I say that it's easier for me
to say that here in Nashville I'm not
I'm not in the middle of a busy season
there in Eugene or whatever
could you create a world where you work
nine hours a day and then go home
is that possible
um
I don't know it seems like it's probably
worth trying though
I think you're worth that I think your
sweet wife is worth that I think those
little baby girls are worth that
and I think honoring the memory of your
two boys
Lawrence sander I think it's worth it
I think it's worth it
but I can guarantee you as the pace
you're moving
with the weight of the bricks you're
carrying is not sustainable
and I love you too much to tell you it's
all good man just just keep crushing
yeah is that fair
yeah I think so yeah and how you choose
to heal and how y'all choose to um
grief is like a fingerprint dude
um ever it's different for everybody
sitting down with your wife and asking
how you're going to grieve this what
does she need
um what does that look like and let's
say this maybe you can't take time off
of work
so hire a high school kid or a college
student to come home for four hours a
night and help your wife out
and you're going to get behind
financially and or not get behind but
you're gonna have to you're going to
stay afloat or you're going to take some
of your business expenses and you're
going to have to roll them back in and
chart you have to pay yourself more for
the hours you're putting in and you take
that money and you roll it back and you
help out with so get your wife some help
so she can get some breathing room
so you can have some space to feel
my wife and I lost three pregnancies and
I tattooed the names of those babies on
my body and it has provided great
conversations for me and my kids as
they've asked questions daddy who's that
and why you have that name right below
our names and what is it so that's
that's how that's the conversation we
had in our house and my wife and I have
had to grieve it differently in
different Cycles throughout our marriage
don't let that split y'all up go into it
direct and be be clear about it man
foreign
unable to lead yourself
sometimes the greatest thing a leader
can do is to take a knee and say
I need to I need to tap somebody else I
need to tap out
and you tap somebody else in
and you stop for a second
I need to call some men who I trust and
I need them to hold my arms up in the
desert because I can't hold them up on
my own right now
I need to call a friend I need to get
some help I need to get some support I
need to hire a couple more people even
though it's gonna really make a tough
financially for us
whatever we got to do
to put your marriage first to put those
two little babies second and then put
the rest of your life after that
but man I'm heartbroken with you I'm
sorry
I want you and your wife to write those
two little boys a letter about how much
you miss them
but all the cool things that you had
planned for them
and I want y'all to read your letters to
each other
and that'll be step one on a new healing
path for you and her and those two
little baby girls
are we thinking about you my brother